in the bus gentlemen you know there's a  right way of doing police work there's a  wrong way of doing it  and there's a way that you two idiots do  it Thank You captain I know what you're  going to say but the fact is you've been  making us who look bad I don't want to  cause any problems lieutenant I just  want a new partner if anything we  deserve a reward or something with the  trophy take this hi Beverly Hills we go  strictly by the book I hear from the  boys upstairs you've been sticking your  nose in a Ralph's don't think don't mix  my Dickens  your ass is on the line don't yes  captain may enough Jimmy don't square  for me with some bullshitting handle me  you think I'm over the hill play a tough  guy doesn't mean you out with your lace  curtain I got up rosewood they planning  you got three days let me see some  results by then I'm gonna pray on your  ass and the dog meat you got that  captain no you're not